del áfrica occidental francesa a este
barrio residencial de quebec itinerario
de un mestizo nacido en la época de las
colonias hijo ilegítimo de un francés y
una madre indígena con hambre día lo
tiene hoy en día 94 años tenía 6 cuando
fue ubicado a la fuerza en un orfanato
de la ottt volta lo que después sería
burkina faso
[Música]
d
me cogieron a jóvenes de mi edad para
permitirle a mi madre que regresara a su
casa sin que yo me enterara
cada vez que veía a una mujer peinada
como mi madre y creía que era ella
bilbao
para ver si x
todos
en aquella época esa era la regla
rechazado por su padre es un hombre
diálogo también fue alejado de su madre
las instituciones de la francia colonial
se encargaron de su educación pasó
varios años en el hogar de los mestizos
de bañar bill en costa de marfil
y miles de niños corrieron con la misma
suerte en áfrica a sus 20 años vio a su
padre por primera vez en senegal donde
estaba hospitalizado
estuve allí
encontré a mi padre postrado en una cama
hizo el esfuerzo y me besó en la mejilla
pero como yo no estaba acostumbrado a
los saludos paternos quedé congelado
nunca antes
recibí lyon que unía
empleado de la administración colonial
leon kun y nunca reconoció a jamón de
djaló pero una carta inesperada llegó
desde francia a principios de los años
80 el hijo de san andrés nos lee un
fragmento
llegó al final de mi búsqueda si quieres
nos volvemos a encontrar mi querido
hermano desde el otro lado del mundo te
envío un abrazo y todo mi amor tu
querido hermano pierdo
[Música]
esta carta fue escrita por días que
onyia uno de los hijos reconocidos de
león nos dirigimos al viejo continente
nos reunimos con viaje on- y en su casa
en toulon se enteró tardíamente sobre la
existencia de su medio hermano burkinés
[Música]
y aquí se puede ver a mi padre con mi
sobrina la hija de gianandrea la derecha
ella vino con jean andré y fuimos a
visitar a todas las familias en los
alpes fue entonces cuando me enteré de
que toda la familia sabía de esto desde
la década de 1930 creo que mi padre
estaba muy feliz de haberlo vuelto a ver
debe haberle pesado la conciencia cuando
tuve
la conmoción
los dos hermanos decidieron recuperar el
tiempo perdido y se reunieron en varias
oportunidades
una de ellas aquí en quebec una prueba
de adn confirmó que su padre es el mismo
león con y no tuvo tiempo de reconocer
oficialmente la paternidad de la madre
djaló
[Música]
le conduce en esa dirección le dije oye
no es normal de vista reconocerlo las
consecuencias de tus actos porque es
importante que un niño tenga un padre y
una madre y la muerte es lo llevó poco
antes de que lograra hacerlo es una pena
ese sentido un arco
como consecuencia son andrew diálogo
jamás obtuvo la nacionalidad francesa a
pesar de decenas de esfuerzos pese a su
estatus de pupilo de la nación y a su
servicio militar bajo la bandera
francesa nada cambió
insistió en reclamar esta nacionalidad
como un derecho médico que una pequeña
reparación francesa cumpliría con
nuestras expectativas
con blog de tu club de autor
tal como él numerosos mestizos del
período colonial se consideran como los
olvidados de la historia muchos expresan
la necesidad de un reconocimiento por
parte de un país al que consideran como
el suyo
[Música]